on va faire tout de suite rentré le père
noël
[Applaudissements]
sauf les yeux
à
je vais laisser une chance à quelqu'un
devait regagner laurent guyot rapa nui
30 est-ce que vous avez un an proposée
matthieu delormeau question oui êtes
vous à mon sens sont deux cas elle voit
des plus grands acteurs
de plus
ilya silik non non non non voilà
bah du coup on a proposé
au maire etes-vous jean pierre castaldi
non
c'est jean pierre castaldi vous fait
gagner mais au robot à tous les publics
même mangé des menteurs mais si ce n'est
pas non mais ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout ça c'est du commerce
[Applaudissements]
merci george michael et il dort jean
pierre castaldi que j'aime ah oui
benjamin as tu sais comme oui mais
cholet mme mercier un cadeau à un
cadeau noël et je sais que cholet mme
bah oui mais ça fait plaisir de voir ben
oui j'adore
me déguiser on voit que sont
pipés de respect
c'était mon père jean-pierre démarche
comme j'espère que tu seras comme ton
père à son âge déjà choisi un réseau
qu'il va beaucoup mieux
[Applaudissements]
en bois matin jean pierre est avec les
auteurs pas le calendrier carats
[Applaudissements]
wasselonne
tiens regarde et si tu veux on se voit
mi mars
oui ça c'est bien c'est pour toi là
c'est pourquoi ces 4